let's get to audience questions for the
week some good ones I'm looking forward
to answering remember to send me yours
via email is best david pakman.com use
the contact form title should be
audience question and maybe it'll be
answered on an upcoming show David who
is more guilty of a plane crash Donald
Trump or Walter White I actually like
this because it does allow us to think
about this plane crash a thing in
slightly different terms so the set up
is after Donald Trump decided to have
Iranian codes leader Kasim soleimani
assassinated Iran shot down a Ukrainian
passenger plane which was flying from
Iran to Ukraine killing everyone on
board
Iran initially denied responsibility
ultimately had no choice but to admit it
yes Iran shot down a fully loaded
passenger plane the argument that some
have put forward is doesn't Trump have
some responsibility for the plane crash
because if Trump hadn't assassinated
Kasim soleimani none of it would have
happened which has a couple of problems
number one is that it totally takes
agency away from Iran as a player that
can discern whether something in the sky
is a passenger plane or not
why did here on decide not to stop all
air traffic knowing that they were going
to be engaged in this bombing campaign
so when you look at the causality chain
you can say well the the catalyst was
Trump assassinating Soleimani Trump
wouldn't have been in a position to make
that call if Hillary Clinton had been
president so don't we need to blame the
people who voted for Donald Trump hey
let's go back even further what about
the parents of the people who birthed
the voters that voted for Donald Trump
the point is you can find a reasonable
place to draw the line in terms of the
causality chain but it can always be
argued to be different now the
comparison here is Walter White in what
is arguably one of the best television
series in history Breaking Bad Walter
White caused a plane to crash in a sort
of similar sense in Breaking Bad as I
remember I'm going from memory here it's
been a while since I watched that watch
the show Walter White and Jesse Pinkman
were partners May
making cooking meth and Jesse Pinkman
was dating a girl whose father happened
to be an air traffic controller the girl
became addicted to meth the very meth
that Walter White and Jesse Pinkman were
cooking thanks to being in this
relationship with Jesse Pinkman she had
ready access to plenty of it she
overdosed and as she was overdosing
Walter White showed up saw her
overdosing saw her starting to choke on
her own vomit and made the decision to
let her die because he believed he made
the call that it would be better for his
business clearly better for his avoiding
law enforcement if Jesse pinkman's
girlfriend were allowed to die rather
than saving her from this overdose in
his grief about his daughter's death the
girl's dad the air traffic controller
makes a mistake while working and causes
a mid-air collision of two planes
killing everybody on board so the
question is well okay what is the
responsibility there versus Trump which
is seemingly more direct Trump
assassinated Soleimani and this led
directly to Iran shooting down a
passenger plane now there were some very
good comments about this on a subreddit
discussion on our subreddit about this
one was of the specific plane crash both
are equally guilty but Trump is more
guilty of the loss of life since his
actions were more likely to cause
additional deaths than Walter White
allowing Jesse pinkman's girlfriend to
overdose and die another comment Iran
general got killed with a drone strike
and Iran shoots down the very first
aircraft that seems to veer off course
when they suspect it's a US missile the
chain of causality is like one ring long
suggesting Trump is far more responsible
but again it takes away agency from Iran
Iran is the one that was unable to I
guess distinguish that this was a
passenger airplane and not a US missile
another comment from the subreddit
neither is guilty of the plane crash
neither could reasonably have foreseen
that their actions would lead to plane
crashes in law we would say each plane
crash was
to remote a consequence of the actions
of both Walter White and Donald Trump
they were not natural consequences
therefore neither is guilty of a plane
crash what do you think I tend to go
with the latter which is that plane
crashes are not reasonably expected
outcomes - allowing someone to overdose
from meth or assassinating Kasim
Soleimani
let me know what you think so you're
someone who enjoys thinking about
politics you love learning about
countless other topics but you just
don't have enough time in your week to
read or listen to all the books you've
been meaning to get to blink astiz an
app that will completely transform the
way that you absorb information and
ideas because what they do is take
thousands of non-fiction books extract
the most important insights and
information and then present each book
to you as text or audio which you can
consume in just 15 minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but it is a reality that there's a
whole world of books out there that you
will never get to but blinka swill
helped you get to more i've just
finished listening to upheaval by Jared
Diamond Jared Diamond a tremendous
author whose work I've previously
recommended excellent book looking at
some of modern history's biggest
national crises to figure out how
different countries ended up in such
precarious situations you'll be able to
have conversations with people about
totally new topics you can feed your
curiosity in ways that you've never been
able to before and the best part is it's
only about eight bucks a month which
gives you unlimited access to every
single book in their catalogue they have
books on politics economics philosophy
science you name it you can try it out
yourself totally free for a week and get
25% off if you decide to subscribe just
by going to blink is calm slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
video like the rest of us I bet you're
going into 2020 thinking about what you
didn't get around to in 2019
your goals for the new year if you want
to work towards being your best self in
2020 understand more about the world
around you and make sure that your time
is well spent then blink astiz for you